♪ (jazz) ♪
- Jack Kerouac est une légende
de la Beion et un des
plus grands écrivains américains
du 20e siècle.
DAVID GOUDREAULT, écrivain
- Jack Kerouac, il est
intemporêtre même
immortel d'un point de vue
littéraire.
♪ ♪ ♪
MICHEL BARRETTE, humoriste
avoir inspiré plein
de monde. T'sais, je pense à...
je pense bien sûr à Bob Dylan,
je pense à Jim Morrison.
- C'était pareil commevivre au t
des cretons, des tourtières.
- Né à Lowell, au Massachusetts,
en 1922, Jean-Louis Kerouac
avait des parents québécois
originaires du Bas-Saint-
Laurent. Celui qui se faisait
appelé Ti-Jean a parlé
seulement en français
jusqu'à l'âge de six ans.
Longtemps restés inédits,
ses écrits en français ont vu
le jour dans le recueil intitulé
"La vie est d'hommages".
- Il y a ce... passage
extraordinaire, bouleversant
où il dit : "Quand je me fâche,
je sacre souvent en français,
quand je rêve, je rêve
souvent en français et,
quand je braille je braille
tout le temps en français."
- Écris jamais rien que
tu as pas vu toi-même.
- Mais de son vivant, c'est
en anglais que Jack Kerouac
a publié ses écrits.
Il y a eu ce premier roman
en 1950, puis la consécratio
en 1957 grâce à son deuxième
une fresque littéraire qui
allait pousser ses admirateurs
à partir à l'aventure.
- Je suis pas à la poursuit
de Kerouac, mais je pense que
Kerouac me poursuit toujours.
Quand je vais être seul dans le
désert à rouler en moto, là,
bien, il y aura Kerouac assis
sur le siège en arrière de moi.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
Merci, Jack Kerouac.
- L'histoire de "On the Road",
c'est pas l'histoire de deux
beatniks; c'est l'histoire
d'un ex-football joueur.
- "Sur la route" est le fruit
de plusis de voyags de voyags de
et d'écriture acharnée.
Il y a du sexe, de la drogue
et du jazz sur une route
faite de rencontres.
evenu,
avec ses amis Neil Cassady,
William Burrough
et Allen Ginsberg,
un des piliers de la Beat
on des années 1950.
- Ça vient de lui, la Beat
Generation. La Beat Generation,
c'est oui, le rythme,
mais c'est d'abord "beat",
c'est d'abord être battu;
lui-même le dit.
- Je suis tanné de moi-même.
(rires)
- Encore aujourd'hui,
le fantôme de Jack Kerouac
habite Chloé Sainte-Marie, qui
chantera deux de ses textes
sur son prochain album.
♪ Et accomplira
dans toute "le" direction ♪
CHLOÉ SAINTE-MARIE, chanteuse
- Il m'habite, moi, comme...
Canadiene...
oui, parce qu'il possède
la langue, il est libre.
Moi, par lui, j'apprends
qui je srends
mon histoire, j'apprends
ce que j'ai renié.
J'apprends... t'sais, alors...
J'ai eu envie de le chanter.
- Je sais que je suis bon
écrivain, un grand écrivain.
Je suis pas un homme de courage.
- Jack Kerouac
17 livres et plusieurs inédits
ont vu le jour après son décès.
Son histoire demeure
un des grands mythes
de l'Amérique moderne.
- Ils sont fiers de Kerouac,
les Américains. Mais au Québec,
on devrait être fiers aussi.
D'ailleurs, moi, je comprends
pas qu'il y ait pas de statue
dans le bas du fleuve
le long de la...
(rires)
... le long de la route.
J'en appelle à la poésie
et la sculpture de Kerouac!
- Jack Kerouac est décédé
en 1969 en Floride; il avait
47 ans. Ici, à Lowell, au
Massachusetts, on célébrera
son 100e anniversaire
de naissance ce samedi.
Avec tous ces homm
des résidents de Lowell sont
déterminés à garder bien vivante
la mémoire de Jack Kerouac.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet, Rad,
au Massachusetts